how does someone who hates reading their
own writing continue to write scripts I
think it's necessary because I was
telling my friend other day actually
about this where I only produce in write
for stuff I want to like director acting
because I personally just might be an
actor director I would love this to be
an actor and director but I like making
my own content and counting my own
stories I guess that's that's the main
reason why do produce because I hate
producing to like I'm good at it which
is like bad too but I'm good at it and
everyone wants me producer stuff and
like no but yeah I just like my mom's
also a writer too like in her own
writing she guys really really well and
I'm sitting I'm like when I was younger
I'm like I'm not gonna be a writer I
must still be a director so I know
aspirations of being like the next
Quentin Tarantino or something like dice
wanna be a director that's my old poles
but just kind of like sit down like oh
like I sometimes I sent to my writer
friends like hey give me give me
constructive feedback and like and they
only laugh because I'm like it's garbage
and like it's garbage tell me it's gonna
be garbage since I'm not looking for
compliments because like I'm the type of
person I don't want compliments I don't
easily give compliments out I always
feel like it's an ulterior motive our
agendas if people try to do that and I
don't do that
and my BS mirror and tolerance to it I
have no filter for outfits like no so
when I see it I'm sitting like Oh like
my last script I was working on I sit
down like oh it's garbage how they want
me to make just look like a throwback
80s horror film but set in contemporary
times it's like and ironically it was me
who pitched it and I'm like like how did
I pull this one out of my hat like I
don't know how I did I'm sitting there
and spending five weeks like the like
hey and that's the thing too is like one
of my methods of writing it kind of
helps me finish writing because it would
never get done I hand write all my
scripts I hand write in first before I
transcript because I look at a blank
screen I'm like I just see a blank
screen oh my god my life sucks I'm gonna
throws computer
but also another method I do to make me
finish the script I always have an idea
but I write the end and I work all the
way to the beginning so a lot of people
like and the reason I started doing it
because everyone has like a beginning a
middle and they start from the beginning
I was watching the film memento and this
was like when I was younger like this is
when I started like using a TIG like
okay I'm gonna take the end of my script
which I know how it's gonna end
and then we'll all work my way back
because then after I do that my second
draft for my third draft I could be like
okay I have a beginning and an end now
and I work forwards to making it like
tighter but I always start with the
ending first because all the time like
just character dies no sequel but that's
what I do for it well you have a great
relationship with your mom you said
earlier but then you said that she's
definitely very honest with you about
writing which you appreciate yeah
definitely she's very OnPoint with my
writing he's like okay this doesn't work
okay this works try to go into more
detail for this so it's like that was
like thinking but she's really like
that's one thing she's really into like
with writing she's a brilliant writer
alright so I'm surprised she's doesn't
like to have some successful career as a
writer but me I'm it's like I'm just a
visual person like I like his when I
write I was explaining to her out of day
cuz she's like why why are you not
having this scene I'm like if I don't
see in my head cuz I see it I see the
whole movie in my head so my goal is
like okay I see the whole movie in my
head I'm gonna write it how I see it
because a lot of people they don't do
that they write the story and then bench
like oh I see the movie doing this doing
that like I don't write like that and
that's also how I see scripts to a lot
of people like hiring me as a director
or sometimes or I could see the script
and I could see in my head and I do what
exactly I see em I see it I always want
to do that's why I like working for
other writers and working as a director
for hire this so to speak where I won't
always be faithful to what the writers
writing and I know how to make it visual
and visually entertaining and a lot of
people can't do that like one of my
friends is a writer and like I did that
one of his short films as a director
packing a long time like 2010
and he was like really happy with it
like oh this is how I want it okay cool
because I visualize it and I see it and
I can see what's going on a page where
it's it's just skill set a lot of people
who work for a trick rider have issues
with that sometimes or it's like oh I
don't know why this and they start
throwing things out of the script I'm
like the script is the blueprint I'm
like it's the basis it's a skeleton like
why are you getting rid of it
just do it and come up with creative way
to make it work so so you send your mom
traps oh I sent her driver I sent her a
draft this morning because I wrote a new
opening of course you turn it in soon
and it looks like I read in the opening
yesterday I wanted a better hook for him
I think as a horror fantasy and in the
beginning the original beginning was
good it was really good but I was like
okay I needed something to make sure to
keep it in mind for the audience like
when they're falling this character like
oh okay something Bad's gonna happen
something Bad's gonna happen
Oh something about no wait is it this
one would no is it this one no but I
sent it to my mom and my mom and even
one of my writer friends - I sent it's
like it does this work because it's like
is it - out of a bone or like no it
actually wrapped the story up perfectly
which I was looks like yes cuz usually I
don't have that like happy stance moment
I'm just like I'm tired like a like
throw script burn I don't want to do it
play it's just like it worked for some
reason because I was just a Starbucks
like 15 minutes and I was like I was to
the point where like I wrote it out and
I was like oh I got to write this fast I
actually wattled home really fast like
oh I got a righteous on my computer like
this is a good start so like that's what
happened but she like she did it and she
also helps like the spell check and
grammar sometimes stuff certain stuff
where I miss or she's like oh there's a
fragment sentence dere and that's not
like oh there's a screenplay not a novel
but yeah so but she she goes good advice
and stuff and she actually really digged
a story so I was like okay guess I'm
doing something all right
and she used to write or she still was
she still write she writes a lot of like
um poetry stuff she has her own blog she
does a lot of arts and crafts stuff too
but she's starting to like write a lot
more again because like she
some stuff I guess like when she was
younger like poetry and stuff that got
published and stuff when she was in her
teens but um yeah she she's a really
good writer like really really good
you